[Music]
in ancient Greece headaches were
considered powerful afflictions victims
prayed for relief from Asclepius the god
of medicine and if pain continued a
medical practitioner would perform the
best known remedy drilling a small hole
in the skull to drain supposedly
infected blood this dire technique
called trepanation often replaced the
headache with a more permanent condition
fortunately doctors today don't resort
to power tools to cure headaches but we
still have a lot to learn about this
ancient ailment today we've classified
headaches into two camps primary
headaches and secondary headaches the
former are not symptomatic of an
underlying disease injury or condition
they are the condition but we'll come
back to them in a minute because while
primary headaches account for 50% of
reported cases we actually know much
more about secondary headaches these are
caused by other health problems with
triggers ranging from dehydration and
caffeine withdrawal to head and neck
injury and heart disease doctors have
classified over 150 diagnoseable types
all with different potential causes
symptoms and treatments but we'll take
just one common case a sinus infection
as an example the sinuses are a system
of cavities that spread behind our
foreheads noses and upper cheeks when
our sinuses are infected our immune
response heats up the area roasting the
bacteria and in flaming the cavities
well past their usual size the engorged
sinuses put pressure on the cranial
arteries and veins as well as muscles in
the neck and head their pain receptors
called nociceptors trigger in response
cueing the brain to release a flood of
neuro peptides that inflamed the cranial
blood vessels swelling and heating up
the head
this discomfort paired with
hypersensitive head muscles creates the
sore throbbing pain of a headache
not all headache pain comes from
swelling tense muscles and inflamed
sensitive nerves caused varying degrees
of discomfort in each headache but all
cases are reactions to some cranial
irritant while the cause is clear in
secondary headaches the origins of
primary headaches remain unknown
scientists are still investigating
potential triggers for the three types
of primary headaches recurring
long-lasting migraines intensely painful
rapid-fire cluster headaches and most
common of all the tension headache as
the name suggests tension headaches are
known for creating the sensation of a
tight band squeezed around the head
these headaches increase the tenderness
of the para cranial muscles which then
painfully pulse with blood and oxygen
patients report stress dehydration and
hormone changes as triggers but these
don't fit the symptoms quite right for
example in dehydration headaches the
frontal lobe actually shrinks away from
the skull creating forehead swelling
that doesn't match the location of the
pain in tension headaches scientists
have theories for what the actual causes
ranging from spasming blood vessels to
overly sensitive nociceptors but no one
knows for sure meanwhile most headache
research is focused on more severe
primary headaches migraines are
recurring headaches
which create a vice-like sensation on
the skull that can last from four hours
to three days in 20% of cases these
attacks are intense enough to overload
the brain with electrical energy which
hyper excites sensory nerve endings this
produces hallucinations called auras
which can include seeing flashing lights
and geometric patterns and experiencing
tingling sensations cluster headaches
another primary headache type cause
burning stabbing bursts of pain behind
one hot leading to a red eye
constricted pupil and drooping eyelid
what can be done about these conditions
which dramatically affect many people's
quality of life tension headaches and
most secondary cases can be treated with
over-the-counter pain medications such
as anti-inflammatory drugs that reduce
cranial swelling and many secondary
headache triggers like dehydration eye
strain and stress can be proactively
avoided migraines and cluster headaches
are more complicated and we haven't yet
discovered reliable treatments that work
for everyone but thankfully
pharmacologists and neurologists are
hard at work cracking these pressing
mysteries that weigh so heavily on our
minds if you're fascinated by the
mysterious things that go on in our
heads we think you'll love the man who
mistook his wife for a hat in which
renowned neurologist Oliver Sacks
recounts some of his patients most
bizarre and captivating case histories
you can download an audio version of
this book for free at audible.com slash
ted-ed every free trial created
encourages audible to continue
supporting Ted's nonprofit mission